um so there was this guy in like seventh
grade that had a crush on me he would
kind of like follow me during school a
lot just because he liked me and I saw
him at lunch you know just like he was
like hiding behind a trash can kind of
like staring at me and I like one up to
him and I said I hate you why do you
exist since that day on he didn't talk
to me or anything and this is probably
the worst thing I've ever said to anyone
so I felt really guilty afterwards I
didn't really say that I was sorry or
anything because I was just like in
middle school and it made me look cool
so I thought it was okay to say things
like that but now like looking back at
it I hope it didn't follow him or
anything if I saw him today I would just
like to say sorry and that he's worth
something and that he's an important
person most painful thing I've ever told
someone was when I was 19 years old and
I told my parents that I was molested by
my brother and they didn't believe me
and it took 20 years later for my
brother to apologize on his own and my
mom to this day still doesn't believe me
that's the most painful thing you are so
comfortable with talking about it what
has got you to this point therapy
therapy and talking about it and and
knowing that knowing that the shame is
not mine
knowing that I was young I didn't
he was older when I spoke up I did what
a 19 year old would do go to support and
when I didn't get it I kept looking for
it because my life mattered and it still
does and I share it pretty comfortably
these days
so a couple years ago I lost my daughter
everybody had a very strong connection
with my daughter and it was
heartbreaking to have to tell each and
every person individually what happened
to her and why she passed she passed
away of SIDS sudden infant death
syndrome okay yeah she had a heart
condition that was passed on for me
so yeah heartbreaking I told my dying
mother that I no longer wanted her in my
life that I can no longer support her
and give her the love and affection that
she wants cuz she ruined too many
chances and when she died I never said
goodbye I think happiness is the most
selfish thing that anyone can do and
sometimes finding your happiness means
you got to make those tough decisions
and let people go sometimes happiness
isn't always sunshine and you know
smiles sometimes it's rain and pain and
suffering and moving on and struggling
and I think it really helped define me
and Who I am and the happiness that I'm
trying to create for myself and it was
tough but it was the best decision for
me so it's not like a single thing but I
used to kind of bully my brother and
call him fat and now I wish that I was
more supportive of him and didn't matter
what he looked like or not and now I
feel he looks more feels more
comfortable about his body image but I
feel like for a long time I was part of
the problem of his body image and I
don't feel good about that
have you expressed this to him mmm you
know now now I talked to him about how I
would only like to support him but I
never actually told him that I felt bad
for pretty much bullying him when we
were younger and that freshman year I
just like I brought me I broke up with a
girlfriend over text like it was the
most terrible way to break up with
anybody I'm not letting this person
anymore obviously you know go through
changes and it became a different person
you know but I I was like your
ex-boyfriends really hot she was like
which one I was like me that was very
painful thing to say
I think it was like a reckless and like
not really caring and like just like -
joking away that you didn't really care
about other people's like doing you know
yeah and what change do you think that
now you actually do care about people's
feelings well I like realizing that you
know like it really matters how you
treat other people you know if you're
not treating anything like it's you -
you know so like treating everything
everyone like everything as it is
yourself yeah saying I love you to my
dad I hadn't said I love you to my dad
like
a really long time and when I said it
during our argument I just like it
didn't feel right and I just don't think
I ever want to say it again unless like
I know it's coming from a good place I
think that's it for me before it like
before now you can't really tell but I
used to be a little bit Brown dairy a
little bit more chubby and a lot of
people would tell me like oh you lost a
lot of weight some people think I lost
the weight in a healthy way but the way
I actually lost it was really unhealthy
and I was just in a really bad it was I
wasn't about timing my life but I just I
straight-up could not consume food or
eat anything the most painful thing that
I experienced was having to actually and
truly explain how I lost weight it was
painful for me to explain because it's
just kind of like oh yeah like that's
the reality of it and that's actually
how I lost everything
linked all the weight but we're good now
we're good now we're thriving I was
really mad and I told like I told like
my family like as a whole that they were
doing like a bad job at being a family
like I don't know what I was saying I
was kind of like mad I was like I love
my family and like we fight a lot but
like they do everything for me as much
as I can I talk to them that day I was
like okay I'm sorry I didn't mean to say
that because I can't go to bed like I
can go to bed being mad at them but I
can't go to bed like having them like
feel that way about me I'm saying yeah
the most painful thing I've told
somebody is I've cheated on you
something I kind of think about a lot
actually and how wrong it was and oh
sorry I am and it kind of likes where
I'm at today
did they forgive you I don't think so
I'm
that I'm
yeah okay wait
okay mmm it was
coming out as not entirely straight to
my boyfriend and
the only reason it was just so painful
is because growing up my family always
kind of teased me that I was gay
so if I never wanted to admit it
so I've only came out to my boyfriend
and no Beals just because I didn't want
them to have a sort of satisfaction that
they were always right I haven't quite
admitted that to my family
some of the people closest to me but
I want to show their beds
yeah the last time I saw my grandma she
she was joking with me about like seeing
my dad and I blew her off and then like
a week later she died I really really
loved her and as a kid growing up I
couldn't speak that much Spanish and I
it was really there was like a language
barrier with us but she would always
like call me like Chiquito chummy cool
or something like that or she would
always just like be really really nice
to me and I just felt like I couldn't I
couldn't be like a good Korean child and
I feel like now like I like singing a
lot and like Spanish and stuff so it's
just like I feel like like now that I'm
older I'm trying to like at least like
honor her in that way the most painful
thing that probably tell somebody it's
tomorrow dad is that I hated him it just
really hurt like he tried to treat me
better and I just did my hand when I
told him that I hate it I'm so about
eight and a half years ago my husband
was hit by a car while riding his bike
and everything basically was broken from
from here to his pelvis and I had the
job of calling his then 90 year old
father to tell him what had happened to
his son and it's really hard to hear a
90 year old guy who's a world war two
vet ball on the telephone and I had to
keep him posted through the whole
recovery and to this day I cannot call
him on the phone because whenever I call
and he answers he thinks something
really horrible has happened so someone
else has to call him and hand me the
phone because he still can't have me
call me you realized that being a parent
never stops that he was still a
nine-year old man with a son and
probably still sees his
little boy and he's hundreds of miles
away and his kids in a hospital broken
and yeah it was pretty pretty poignant
moment okay so how does it make you feel
hearing that story it reminds me of the
whole situation everything she says
about you never stop being a parent well
one that jumps out at me and I can't
believe it still bothers me to this day
12 years ago or more my daughter who's
in her 30s now was in college and she
was giving short answers to family
members when they'd call and just really
not being too interested instead of
actually asking her what was going on or
whatever I read her the riot act over
the phone
and brought her to tears and I felt so
terrible for doing that
and she couldn't she barely talked at
the other end because I did that so we
there's a series of phone calls
afterwards where he made amends and all
that stuff but she was so far from home
it seemed like and I couldn't believe
that I made her cry over something so
trivial okay
when we were going to help my sister's
boyfriend proposed to my sister my
brother and I got into a fight like on
the way up there and I told him that her
fiance didn't even like him and that he
wasn't really a part of the family and
stuff like that it was really awful like
the moment it came out of my mouth I was
like oh I can't believe I would ever say
something like that especially in such
like a beautiful moment you know they're
best friends and my brother looks up to
him so much so it was a really low it's
Jeb he got really silent and that's how
I knew that I'd like really crossed the
line
because usually he would like yell at me
every I pretty much apologize like the
moment it came out of my mouth because I
realize that was just awful so yeah
we're good now though it makes me more
conscious of everything that I say
because I've seen how hurt other people
can be by you just your words
so I think reversing the question which
is what we did on today's episode really
shines light on the fact that we're all
human and sometimes we make bad
decisions and use the wrong words and
obviously that's not okay that's not
what I'm saying
but you can still be a good person who
makes a bad decision and the important
thing is to realize that you did
something bad or said something hurtful
and try not to do it again and obviously
ask for forgiveness that helps too
that's pretty much it thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you next week
[Music]